[Music]
General we are
discovered
good
wait nice it's a
CL I'm not built like other
men General's G GED in their
masses move along now those in power
only see me as a Gro unfit for higher
office just like witches at black m but
I follow in the footsteps of Alexander
the Great and
Caesar evil minds plot destruction if
you look down you'll see a
surprise once you see it you will always
want it Sorcerer of death Construction
I must warn you I will not lead a second
of
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it the top my own
head
is where the's
burning you want to be great but you
want nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
will all sleep again without This
Vermin whose country are we
in
[Music]
mine gotcha so you're the funny little
man who's been following me funny little
man how dare you I will have you know
that I am a perfectly respectable size
for an OA Luma an OA what now in fact in
Lumpa land I am regarded as something of
a Whopper they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie won you see
I'm something of a magician prepare to
be amazed a
taper inventor may I present Willy
Walker's wild and wonderful wishy-washy
WKA Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate Baker the best
chocolate in the
world
ooh he's good too good and anyone can
afford them even the the poor he doesn't
like it when people say poor send Wonka
a message do not sell chocolate in this
town you're going to get more than a
bonk on the head I love a bonk on the
head what is with me
today you should stand up to those
Buddhist give them the old one too
I got an idea where do we start making
chocolate of
course
R every good thing in this world started
with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world I'm not in premium e good night
sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
well huh you did it again tell me what
it is or I shall poke you quite
viciously with a cocktail
[Music]
stick ever since I was a child people
said my family was
cursed mom tried to protect us with
God pop tried to protect us with
wrestling he said if we were the
toughest the strongest nothing could
ever hurt us
I believed him we all
did morning pants tomorrow please
David Harry I want you to join your
brothers in the ring yes sir I love that
now we all know Carrie's my favorite
then Kev then David then Mike but the
rankings can always change what do you
want in life Kevin ER more ribs I want
to be with my family you know be with my
brothers what do you like to do with
your
brothers and
David together we can do
anything we're here to restore Justice
to the Wrestling Federation that our
father built with his own two hands the
hands that were passed down to us the
hands that will deliver the iron claw to
you so what do you think like we're aive
I love your family
C you going to be an uncle yes sir oh
man that makes me so happy I talk to you
about something tomorrow dad's too tough
on us you got to say something maybe
that's what your brothers are for you
feel that you feel that that's
pressure me you pushing too hard I'm
fine giid seriously I'm just
sick God I'm scared man all my had of
control was a terrible
accident could have stopped him I need
to think about my family your job is to
wrestle live up to that deal while we
are
through I to look out for him I just
love being out there with you guys it's
the only thing that matters to me the
will forever be the greatest family in
the history of
[Applause]
[Music]
wrestl
there are some moments in life you never
[Applause]
forget the Depression hit everyone hard
no jobs no food we were broke looks like
you still owe a balance on this
semester so what's that about making
some money yeah the Rowan team you're
you get a part-time job included she
place to live Amman crew is the most
difficult team sport in the
world the average human body is just is
not meant for such
thing most of you will not be chosen
beautiful speech
coach they're announcing the team today
are you going to make it we rode out of
need come on boys the need to stay in
school the need to eat to S we got to
keep these right long as we stay on the
team Washington Huskies coach is
bringing an inexperienced vote to
competition they said we couldn't
compete with the rich of school for the
nation the Washington po has taking the
lead Washington has
I got 9 seconds under the course record
Olympic year this year Olympic GE I
didn't realize that bunch of kids load
like no one else that's ever come
through here everybody else tires and it
just get stronger we have it both I
believe could qualify for an Olympic
spot hope you know what you're
doing they said we couldn't beat the
Germans got to beat those other schools
first but coach says we had a shot maybe
we can roll as a team if you guys don't
get yourselves figured out you're not
racing at all the boys that
boat fer but they didn't understand who
we were let's show what was in this
book I don't believe what I'm
[Applause]
seeing best they
connected sweating
pain what is worth I'm proud of you boys
inspiring uh you missed the part where I
told him not to tip over and I W groll
for your country grow for each other for
all the people who never believed in you
as one as
[Music]
One Wing
deployment
Elin here we
go wo yeah
[Music]
this isn't about
migration it's about
Adventure is that a little scary sure
you need a
hug can you let go now you feel better
no then it hasn't kicked in
yet there's a whole world we've been
missing out
on things we didn't even know
existed
what is that dange what
dange it's you with larange on
[Applause]
top oh look what the Cat Dragged In good
afternoon
e
how's your day Dad it was a day just
another day my day was a doozy it's one
of those days you never
forget listen up this young lady is our
new prison
psychologist she may be easy on the eyes
but I assure you she is very
smart I'm Rebecca I
know I don't think I caught your
name
oopsie nasty habit that's why I like it
I live a little differently than most
people they probably scared
you prison is not place for a young lady
you got a big life ahead of you I'm sure
I'm just kind of average I think you
really think you're a normal
person I bet you have brilliant
dreams alen may I confide in you people
are so ashamed of their
eyes I have my own
ideas kind
ideas you can never tell anyone do you
understand promise me
okay that will make you
crazy that will make you
pill can't imagine you with a knife can
you imagine me with a
gun that's very good I yeah I can see it
ah
you're different these
days almost interesting secrets and lies
some things are so
Twisted the only way I ask for someone
to
[Music]
die that was a great
trick I hate the way that I know
you and I need
you I don't want to but I want you yeah
I
ha let's just tell everyone we're
together
what could be kind of
fun there's no way we can convince
anyone we actually like each
other trust me we're at a wedding A
Million Miles Away From Home who knows
what could happen be off
[Applause]
[Music]
me convincing enough I the way
I love
[Music]
you
I still believe in
Heroes see
flashes we found you made you one of us
not as strong as you think I know a
renegade so didn't want to see one where
you going to kill Thanos
Avengers the
annihilator you took everything from me
now I'm returning the favor
she's targeting the people that I care
about from every place I call
home she's trying to start a
war what are you prepared to
do give her help watch
me the marveles pg-3 in theaters
November 10th get tickets
now it's real
complicated sometimes you got to do one
thing even though you mean to do another
thing but I'm not in any kind of trouble
at all none at all killers of the flower
moon is the best movie of the
year my life he likes her nice thing so
not as much as you
do you're picking a fight with the wrong
person competion will be dead you're
going to make trouble make it
big you got to just you got to tell me
what you told them all of it what you
tell them I tell them all of it all of
it oh my
God have you told all the
truths
the devil
is what the hell were you doing you're 3
hours late dad you don't understand the
car was busted so we had to shred why
your lips red were you eting a snow cone
that's a really good guess what kind of
adults roll BL the police are here and
they're saying that you bought alcohol
for miners thanks Boys in Europe the
drinking age is like 10 they could have
been European what made you think they
were European they had a certain gen qua
I think one of them was eating pant on
shakala
guys everyone thinks we're losers but
that's about to
change I know where The Treasure of
Foggy Mountain is from when we were kids
we are looking at 100 Mil $100 million
it'd be like I mean I know it's more
than this but at least a million dollar
each significantly more what are we
waiting
for the cute guys that came in earlier I
didn't see nobody cute the ginger look
like a colonial ghost glasses look like
Tim Burton Drew him and in a short one
we probably would have said same size
bra they had a treasure map with like an
x on it we going to steal that
map that is a full on Hawk hey buddy R
it the
rock does it not know it can fly why did
it walk away with an attitude everyone
is after this treasure we deserve that
you deserve it yeah three white guys
whose biggest issue is what growing up
no I feel like it's more nuanced than
that you just hit a woman apologize for
him I for one would
never oh my God so I've H one woman
that's not in the
grand welcome new friends we can all
agree this is a scary cult and we're
waiting for the other shoe to drop we're
in a docu series and this is episode two
dude
completely insane night guys why are we
tied
up I'd rather die than live without you
boys holy
oh guys look dude that's that's the
treasure door open
it would be SI I would be sick to my
stomach forget the money it's not worth
it
[Music]
go
fore fore
fore foreign
spee
fore
[Music]
for foreign
spee
how did you come to write this book what
really struck me was that too few books
were about my people where are our
stories where's our representation would
you give us the pleasure of reading an
excerpt yo surara girl you be pregnant
again if I is Ray Ray is going to be a
real father this time
around thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you Monk your books are good but they're
not popular editors they want a black
book they have a black book I'm black
and it's my book you know what I
mean look at what they publish look at
what they expect us to write I just want
to rub their noses l
i' be standing outside in the night then
be dads rappers crack you said you
wanted black stuff that's black right I
see what you're
doing we sold your book no we believe Mr
Lee has written a bestseller it's a joke
the most lucrative joke you've ever told
now is stag a pseudonym yeah Mr Lee
can't use his real name is this based on
your actual
life
yeah you think some ass college
boy can come up with that no no no
I
don't can I ask what you were in for was
a murder you said that n me they ran
300,000 copies your books Chang people's
lives they're offering $4 million for
movie rights yes the Dumber I behave the
Richer I
get this has gone too far stag Arley is
still on the run for authorities you
haven't done anything it's not like they
can arrest
you it wish I could go back to not
selling books is it bad to cater to
people's taste people want to love you
Monk you should let them love all of you
there's already so much Buzz because of
the movie deal Michael B Jordan is
circling we want to put him on the cover
in one of those um scarves I guess you
would call them tied around his head a
doag doag that's it doag in a tank top
with the muscle shelling something
called the fire
department
we're thinking we can get it out in
H
for
Fore
foree
[Music]
spe
fore
[Music]
fore oh
[Applause]
[Music]
how come you don't laugh n ain't you got
something to make you just
smile
my sister and I ain't seen her in
years you know if you ain't going to
laugh you need to sell your footy
bone I was married to a man I didn't
love whatever I say
[Music]
go and he took my sister away from me
even if we have to part you and me us
have one
how come you so nice don't know maybe
you too
nice you seem like trouble I come here
out of
respect but if there ain't nothing to
get that show ain't none
[Music]
again now that I got your
attention here what you me need through
here drink
some push the button there going to be
some change is
made you got to stand
up I know my sister somewhere in the
world someday we're going to meet
again keep your head held high just like
mom taught us it's time I be free from
you and then turn into creation die
before I let that happen good that's
just a going away present I've been
needing baby baby
[Music]
baby what are you got to do time for you
to see the world push the button
sweet and loving
God
[Music]
a I need your practice am Mount of
reindeer what why are you like this
thank you so much
baby a lot of SP wow Merry Christmas oh
sh what's Christmas without a little
tear check that list twice was your
Christmas
wish I just want it to be the best
ever oh ignore all the fine print
honestly it's like you're signing your
life away away away
this is
crazy hold up that was your wish not
like I don't know world peace and hunger
and homelessness stop climate change say
the polar bears new Drake album oh I
love Drake Point
Tak oh my God oo look at you high stuff
looking like a tall drink of water I'm
enchanted
[Music]
looks
go
did you know there was a college
Christmas party tonight NFI me and you
not
invited you all right yeah I've got a
flat tire take my bike hey that is so
kind thank you I'm sorry I don't know
your name I'm I'm Felix Oliver Oliver
Oliver I love you I love I love you all
right cheers
Ollie my parents they've got problems
what kind of what do you mean problems I
don't think I'll ever go home home again
well why don't you come home with me
come to
salurn Mr Quick wow and here he is now
oh what beautiful eyes oh how wonderful
yeah I told you he wasn't a minger oh
but darling you're kind about everyone
you can't be
trusted I had them hang up an old school
dinner jacket we dressed for dinner here
dressed for dinner yeah it's like it's
like black
tie
I think I like you even more than last
year's
one you're so um so what real can't it
being easy for Venicia with you being a
mother
why now it's time to take things up a
notch should I have them Apple Bottom je
boots with the
fur
this
place you know it's not for
you lots of people get lost in salt
bur oh that's just giving me goosebumps
look Pamela oh
no I think you're a
m quiet harmless drawn to shiny
things what are you doing
I just thought that maybe I could help
you're not leaving us you're not leaving
S I don't think I'll ever go home
again hey thanks for coming come on
let's get her in she's lost a lot of
blood
no idea and had multiple
aerations he's
coming I'm with Social Services I'm not
going to hurt you do you know who did
this to
you anything on that girl last night let
us do our
jobs girls have been disappearing around
for
years this place never
disappoints What If there really is
someone out there killing lots of
them what are you feeling that
me women get reported missing all the
time and most of them turn out to be
nothing be
ready these type of situations l call
stay the out of my
job there some asking just a lot
of questions
Fe
down so beautiful you hear the reason
you just couldn't leave it alone could
you I just need a little more
time darling this is your
salvation
[Music]
for
foreign
[Music]
spee
fore
[Music]
spee